>>Narrator: While most of her fellow
students are hitting the books
at 10:00 A.M. Zoey McNealy is
pursuing gold medal dreams.
She can do much of her school work
any time of the day or night thanks
to the online offerings
of Virtual High School.
>>Nancy: Zoey's been doing the VHS
classes since she was a freshman
at Hudson High School, and
it really made the schedule
for her skating much better because
the after-school skating ice is
so much more crowded than the
daytime skating ice so it allowed her
to leave school during the
day so that she could skate
on an ice surface that didn't
have 20 children skating on it.
>>Zoe: In tenth grade I took a
writing class and a Holocaust class.
And then this year I
took Personal Finance
and now I'm taking Honors
Environmental Science.
So I can log on anywhere that has
Internet access so it allows me
to either access the work at
competitions or I can access it
when I come home and get
the work done that I missed
without really missing anything.
>>Narrator: Virtual High School
is a nonprofit collaborative
of over 300 high schools in 26
states and 16 foreign countries
that offers more than 150 high
school courses over the Internet.
Each participating school
contributes a course to the mix.
>>Liz: They agree to free up
a teacher one period a day
to teach a course online and VHS
provides the training services
for that classroom teacher to learn
how to effectively teach online.
>>I think a really critical element
of a good online course is the
ability to build a community
of learners in that course.
We design our courses so
that the students are engaged
in online activities, they're engaged
in online collaboration
through group projects.
These students are
gaining the information
and communication technology literacy
skills that they're going to need,
not only to do well in high
school but to do well in college
and to do well in the workforce.
>>Narrator: Virtual High School
Cofounder Shelly Berman sees VHS
as a way to take learning
to the next level.
>>Shelly: We've had a
concept here that we wanted
to provide opportunities for
students to take advanced courses,
to take specialized courses,
to try to accelerate their learning
whether they are having significant
challenges in the classroom, or
whether they're very advanced
and can move rapidly
through material.
>>Zubin: This is almost
like a textbook.
All of my controls are here.
>>Narrator: For Zubin Patel VHS means
taking advanced computer science
courses like cryptography at home.
>>Zubin: The VHS basically
allows me to take these courses
that aren't offered at school.
It means extra work.
It means staying up
some nights until 3:00
in the morning doing
VHS work but you have
to do what you have to do.
>>Narrator: For special
needs student Katherine Hoar,
VHS means learning how to learn.
>>Katherine: I write slower than I
talk like I think about it faster
in my head than I write it.
On a computer I type faster than can-
I type fast so it gets all my ideas
out faster that way
and I can spellcheck
and make sure my punctuation
is correct and make sure
that there isn't any
missed words in a sentence
because I notice I
have a lot of that.
>>Narrator: For Hudson's Music
Program Director, Jason Caron,
VHS meant learning a
new way of teaching.
He took the virtual school's 15-week
teacher training covering subjects
like how to foster online discussions
before developing his own VHS course
in American Popular Music.
>>Jason: The students get two
compact discs with excerpts of music
and they also get a videotape.
Their job is to listen to that music
or watch the video, and then discuss
with their online classmates what
they listened to and what they saw.
The tone in our voice
doesn't get transmitted
over the Internet connection.
So you have to have to be very
careful with wording and really spell
out your expectations and that's,
you know, the hindrance I guess
of being disconnected from
the students physically.
But a lot of it is
quite the same too.
You build collaborative projects,
you do a lot of community building
activities to try to find the sense
of the class and the personality of
the individuals in the class too.
>>Teacher: Yeah, you can click right
up here and just drag that title out.
>>Narrator: The rigorous
teacher training
and engaging course designs
seem to be paying off.
The completion rate for VHS courses
is 90 percent, and the VHS pass rate
for advanced placement
courses is 10 percent higher
than the national average.
But even Shelly Berman believes high
schools must maintain a balance.
>>Shelly: I don't believe you can
have a completely virtual education.
I don't think that we- it's
appropriate for students
to have all their courses virtually
and I think the social environment
of the high school is an
important environment.
>>Narrator: For Zoey McNealy VHS
offers the best of both worlds.
>>Zoe: It's almost what an actual
class would offer you except you're
able to do it on your own.
>>Nancy: The skating has opened up
a world for her that is incredible
and without the VHS class I really
don't think we would have been able
to do it.
But I have come to the point where
even if she stopped skating today,
I would continue having
her do those VHS classes.
That's how much I really like
her being able to do that.